……イブ
今日はクリスマス。
はじめさんとこの後
ご飯に行くんですけど
全然来ないっすね。💢
まだか…
あっ！
（楽しそうなメロディー♫）
はじめ軍団入場！　〜♫
はじめさん何してるんすか？
いやなんか
トナカイのコスプレして歩いてたら
皆ついてきちゃって
ま）ハハ///
守ってくれるんすよ今日
ま）苦笑
なんか
ま）すごい
クリスマスだから
ま、でもなんかせっかく
みんなサンタのコスプレしてるからさァ
ちょっと街でも歩いてくるわ
また飯あとで…
行くか！！
ハンター↑
Merry Christmas!!
少年）ｲｪｪｪｴｴｴｴｴｴｱｱ!!
さぁ　はじめ軍団！どんな面白いことを見せてくれるのか！？
いやー　それにしてもはじめさんは　何を着ても
MO☆YA☆SIですね。
ここまでもやしだと、我々も何も言えませんよ。
いや？シャー芯の方がいいか？？？？
いや、やっぱりもやしだ。
ここからは、馬鹿騒ぎ終了までのカウントダウンを始めちゃうよ！！
みんなぁぁぁぁぁ！盛りあがっていこー！！
...............
何があっても、交通ルールは、守りましょうね！
右手をぉぉぉぉ、
しぃぃぃぃぃぃぃっかり！
あげましょうね！
ばか騒ぎ終了まで8秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まで7秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まで6秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まで5秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まで4秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まで3秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まで2秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まで1秒
はぁぁい！ここも手を、しぃぃぃぃぃぃぃっかり！
☆A☆GE☆MA☆SYO☆U☆NE☆
ばか騒ぎ終了まであと7秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まであと6秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まであと5秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まであと4秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まであと3秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まであと2秒
ばか騒ぎ終了まであと1秒
だ、誰か！はじめちゃんにこの服を…
この服を！買ってあげてぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇ！！
ヤンキー軍団で、パシャ！📷✨
あなたの学校で流れるアレ　〜♫
マネージャー）わーはじめんだ！
パシャ！📷✨
はぁ？！
おい、盗撮したぞ！！！！
確保ぉ！
これが、地獄の鬼ごっこのはじまりだった…
吐
クリぼっちは…
...................
クリぼっちは！！！
（息を吸い込む音）スゥゥゥゥゥゥゥぅぅぅぅぅぅ!!!!!
嫌なんだぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！！！！
………
merryChristmas。
と、ゆう夢を見たはじめだった。。